Battlefield 5 flops completely
Fortnite gets a new very important update
keep watching  to find out what it is
NASA gets a furry
What?
And once again, youtubers are crying about how hard their life is
boo boo
I'm Poppy Harlow *pops*
and you're watching Pew News®
Our first story comes from Battlefield 5
An analist predicts that EA's 'Battlefield 5' will be a "serious disappointment".
Preorders lag 'Call of Duty' by more than 85%
DAAAAAMMMN
I know, you feel it too don't you
anyone but EA, America's 5th most hated company
Ah, couldn't this please happen to anyone else now?
now I'm just Poppy Harlow. I'm not supposed to give my own opinion or speculation on this show, but I think
Ok, I think I might have a clue of why the Battlefield 5 preorders are doing so poorly.
But I think it might have something to do with the Battlefield 5 trailer
Completely flopping, getting four hundred and sixty thousand dislikes
as opposed to three hundred thirty four thousand likes,
making it the worst reveal trailer in their history.
And it seemed to focus more on pushing some form of social justice agenda
as opposed to just focusing on making it the coolest trailer they could make.
You see this? That's a girl with a bionic arm.
That's right. They exist in World War 2, and if you don't think so, then you're just uneducated
Oh, you think I'm joking? No, that's what EA actually responded and said.
*laughs*
"Accept it or don't buy the game"
The chief design officer of Battlefield, Patrick Soderlund said:
"We felt like in today's world - I have a 13 year old daughter that
when the trailer came out and she saw all the flak, she asked me, 'Dad,
why is this happening?' She plays Fortnite, and says, 'I can be a girl in Fortnite.
Why are people so upset about this?'" And Soderlund responded with *punch*
WE PLAY THE SIMS IN THIS HOUSE OR BATTLEFIELD!
I'm just kidding. That's not what he said.
What he said was "as a parent, how the heck am I gonna respond to this?
And I just said 'You know what? You're right. This is not okay'".
Then they go on to say "These people who are uneducated
they don't understand that this is a plausible scenario." Hey guys uh
you remember that plausible scenario where the
girl with the bionic arm in World War 2 just made everyone look completely like fools
I had no idea what they were doing. Remember her remember that that's a plausible scenario
Everyone knows that are you uneducated or something like that?
Ya dingus. Then finally Patrick Soderlund said "we don't take any flack
We stand up for the cause, because I think those people who don't understand it
well, you have two choices: either accept it or don't buy the game. I'm fine with either or it's just not okay.
What is this?
Electronic Art chief design officer is leaving!
What?!
just two moths before the launch of the new installment of one of it's biggest franchises, battlefield
Patrick Soderlund has been with EA for nearly 20 years
Earlier this month Crowen  said pre- order sales of battlefield 5 have been weak. This is really strange
You know, I shouldn't be putting pieces together, but I think I understand what happened here this response to me
It sounds like someone that just doesn't care
it's someone that doesn't want to take criticism or at least not trying to understand what the criticism is and
instead you're drawing the line in the sand between your consumers and what your
ideology is. And this is the problem that you face when you push social politics into video games because
Like any politics is all about making your opponent seem like a villain
So you're basically making your consumers the villain here and he's saying well if you don't like what we're trying to do here you're uneducated
Don't buy the game and instead of trying to understand what the actual
Criticism he's making the criticism seem like "oh
You're just uneducated or you're just a sexist or all you don't want to see women in video games, huh?
Is that the problem?", when really that's not the problem at all.
Patrick is not wrong for saying that today's gaming is gender diverse or he's not wrong for looking after the interests of his daughter
in video games. If the option was just for females to be a playable character in battlefield 5 no one would care, but this
Trailer showed so clearly that you care more about pushing this agenda
Than making a cool trailer. That's a problem. It's a statement this trailer. It's basically saying "hey, huh?
What do you think about this? Huh? What's your opinion about this? Huh? Look what we did"
That's why people don't like it and instead of trying to acknowledge that and trying to understand that
He says that everyone else is just uneducated. So it's no surprise really that he was let go after this
I don't really want to celebrate people losing their job or whatever, especially working so long
But maybe this would have been for the better. I understand that. It's a good intention just really bad execution
Then the cluster if you haven't followed the marketing for battlefield 5
It gets worse from here if you can *laughs*
For some reason they decided to hire Trevor Noah to market battlefield 5
Trevor Noah, of course, which everyone knows as a battlefield veteran everybody
I don't know about you guys but whenever Trevor Noah opens his mouth I just cannot stop laughing.
He's just too funny.
Welcome everyone to the battlefield 5 live reveal
I'm your host for this evening Trevor Noah, and I'm so excited to be here introducing this new edition of battlefield
Which for some reason everyone has really assumed this battlefield 5 I mean and not battlefield V, could be V, why not V?
It stands for vagina! *claps and laughter*
See, I don't even need writers to do the work for me. I'm way better.
No offense to Trevor if people like him great.
but he's clearly so fake and it's so
painfully transparent during this
reveal that they did - the remarks he makes are so cringy
Trevor: co-op is back and that's one of my favorite aspects of Battlefield 1
Felix: Battlefield one?! Oh...
Trevor: favorite aspects of Battlefield 1
First and foremost, Trevor Noah.
Trevor: first and foremost
I'm a gamer.
"favorite aspects of Battlefield one"
I'm a gamer, first and foremost everybody. You would expect anyone to believe this? Yikes, ok.
Trevor: Wow, the car, the thing, the man, the boo
You saw the thing man. Uh-huh. I hope they got insurance. That was insane. Do you see that?
How many millions do they spend on this look at it. They built this whole set, right? They hired Trevor Noah
How much do you think this cost?
I feel bad cuz clearly there's so many bad decisions being made by a minority of people
I'm sure there's plenty
of really talented people working on this game.
Dice is a very good studio
I think they made some amazing games that I'm really a big fan of,
But it seems like you got the wrong people making the wrong decisions
and I I don't know I feel bad for all the other people working on it cuz there's probably a massive team on it
It's gone so far that even the fans of battlefield 5 themself are memeing the whole thing.
(Gru's plan meme) mess up the reveal, tell people not to buy the game if they don't like it, people don't buy the game
What?! People don't buy the game! Big shocker everyone
(infinity meme) Fans: Did you completely f up the marketing for this game? EA: Yes
Fans: What did it cost?
EA: EVERYTHING
(poppy pops again)
that's it for the - that
next news (meme review clap)
Here's a sentence I never thought I would say:
A furry got accepted into NASA. That's right.
2018 everybody. What a time to be alive. On Twitter, Naomi H tweeted:
everyone shut the f up I got accepted for a NASA internship
Then, Homer Hickam, or Haickam, I don't know, tweeted back saying "language."
then Naomi (laughs)
(faceplam and tries to not laught )
tweeted back
Suck my dick and balls I'm working at NASA
Homer responded with "I am on the National Space Council that oversees NASA"
*sings* What's this? *laughs*
"NASA intern loses job after vulgar tweet" Oh my god
This is just too funny. It's too good. How did this happen?
How do you not look up who you're tweeting at if you
tell someone to suck your dick and balls? They got the most irresponsible
person I know, even I would do that a
A simple Google search and you would know that Homer Hickam is a former NASA engineer who trained the first Japanese astronaut
Jesus Christ
So basically, Homer wasn't the one responsible for Naomi losing
Her internship, he made a response to this saying he wasn't offended by the word
He was actually looking after Naomi to make sure that this wouldn't get her in trouble
And the fact was that actually all the people that kept hating on Homer for tweeting this
Actually are the ones that brought it to NASA's attention
because they used a ashtag NASA ashtag or whatever, and the ones that actually were
responsible for the recruit - the recruitment
of this individual, saw it and then decided. Well, we can't let this person come on board, which is pretty understandable
I'm not for anyone losing their job or internship or whatever. I hope that this person do actually get another chance
But it's really funny
Nevertheless just from the sense of "haha screw you guys self justice instant self justice"
It's funny. I think most people can agree on that
(poppy pops again )
NEXT NEWS
Fornite gets an update
You can now press down to thank the bus driver before jumping in Fortnite
*claps* We did it guys
We did it. Our memes made an influence. I'm so proud
we chilled this In a meme review in June talking about the bus driver meme
Immediately you guys started memeing it on the PewDiePie's subreddit the same day
It came out people started tweeting
There should be an option where you can thank the bus driver
and they listen so now
Thanks to thanks to the power of memes
We made a positive impact in the world and you can now thank the bus driver in Fortnite
I've never been this pride - proud. Give yourself a pat on the back everybody, we did it.
Fornite has officially become the best royale game. I'm sorry PUBG, you had your chance.
NEXT NEWS
Youtubers are feeling the burn
OOOH
What are they complaining about now? Huh? I don't want to hear this Swedish millionaire complain again
Alright, the reason I'm bringing this up is because uuh
It got a lot of mainstream media attention that youtubers feeling fatigued or worked out
It was covered by The Guardian and the Telegraph and Polygon, I actually didn't hate their article, how about that?
They also mentioned my video in it. I made a video again
I think a month ago or something like that
where I talked about - I try to give some insight on what it's like to be a use of creator and I did this mainly
Because I think a lot of people think that just because you get money and fame all your other problems will go away
And I try to get some insight to explain
Why that isn't necessarily the case. I know it's really tired and overhearing me talking about this
But I think this video probably played a big impact on this getting more attention, which I'm really glad about. I
Luckily don't feel burn out. I feel better than I ever done on youtube. And this is all really thanks to
Me making better decisions
I think and also you guys.
It's so easy to get caught up with the numbers and this is what these articles are talking about because if you take a break
It'll be a problem. And I feel bad seeing a lot of my friends suffer from this as well feeling burned out
Feeling really worn down
because of it and that's why I made that video to hopefully give people insight because I think the more people
UNDERSTAND each other the world will be a better place. That's right. That's all I care about.
I just want people to be happy trust me. That's my number one priority.
Smash a like on this video so i will get more views that will help me out a lot
Thank you very much for watching. Make sure to hit sponsor
(poppy pops again ,but this time he explodes)
so become a sponsor so you can see that and
That's it for me for now. Thank you guys so much for watching. I'll see you guys tomorrow.